the kazakh president has authorized
security forces to fire without warning
as he tries to put down violent protests
against his government
kasim jomah tokyo just made an address
to the nation declaring there will be no
negotiations with those he deemed armed
bandits
dozens of protesters and security
personnel have been killed in days of
unrest across central asia
the central asian country rather this
week russian-led forces have been
deployed to help the government
robin first walker is monitoring
developments from tbilisi in georgia so
robin let's start with the latest orders
from the president shoot without warning
how is that going down how's that being
received
let's talk about that first of course
yes well he has only just come off the
air uh but uh these are these this is
really tough words from from the
president of kazakhstan to that he has
personally given the order to fire
without warning uh and that he said we
are dealing with terrorists and bandits
they have to be destroyed and it will be
done
shortly um and if he ordered uh asked
for csto uh support in order to restore
the constitutional order but he did add
that their mission was for the short
term that they would not be there in
indefinitely that they would be there
for a short period of time certainly um
this is a very
difficult uh
speech i think he's had to give to the
kazakh people what's what was perhaps
disappointing for those who want reforms
is that they all seem to be lumped
together
in that he referred to
civil society groups and others that
had been somehow responsible for for
being behind this mayhem so i'm very
much fighting aggressive talk from the
president
fighting aggressive talk from the
president what about the street i know
it's difficult to get information out
but do we know our protests going on
have the streets calm down
well the internet is still down across
substantial parts of the country and
almost certainly in almaty where
most of the violence has been taking
place
we know how difficult it is right now
for ordinary civilians
a lot of people have been sheltering
inside their homes because there is a
lot of ammunition a lot of live rounds
being fire day
and
that is affecting people's ability to to
do basic ordinary things we've seen cues
outside bakery stores we've seen cues
for bread queues outside petrol stations
for for fuel people are not able to make
electronic payments without the internet
so people are really really struggling
and to get a sense of that um when you
look at the pictures when you see what's
happening on the streets uh you can
understand why let's take a look now at
my report on what's been going on in
almaty
kazakhstan's government calls it an
anti-terror operation
military units on the streets of
kazakhstan's largest city almaty
authorized to use lethal force against
protesters
earlier some of the protesters overran
police units and distributed weapons
security forces have confirmed at least
18 officers killed and more than 700
wounded
the number of civilians dead or wounded
is unknown
but video circulating on social media
appears to show morgues filling up with
bodies
this is violence on a scale not seen in
kazakhstan's modern history
including mass looting of businesses
fuel price rises provided the spark but
these protests are about long-standing
and legitimate grievances
economic and political stagnation and
the corrupt authoritarian elite
anger across the country has been
directed at the official leader of the
nation first president no sultan
nazarbayev
his statue toppled in the city of
taldikorgan
his whereabouts
unknown on thursday president tokyo took
an extraordinary step inviting a
russian-led military deployment to
secure his authority
under this collective security agreement
i have today appealed to the leaders of
the csto to help kazakhstan deal with
this terrorist threat
it's no longer a threat what's happening
is undermining the integrity of the
state
flying in russian troops under the guise
of the moscow-led security block the
csto could prove decisive that brussels
has urged moscow not to exceed its
mandate it goes without saying that such
intervention should respect the
sovereignty and the independence of
kazakhstan
many in kazakhstan will be wondering
which is worse the violence or the
prospect of their nation depending now
on russia to keep the peace
so we're all trying to figure out at the
moment the reasons behind
president tokyo's request for csto
assistance um it's perplexing uh to many
why he would so quickly ask for
foreign troops on kazakh soil and and
how it all happens so quickly within
less than 24 hours and we understand now
that uh troops are flying in
mainly from from from the russian uh
contribution but also from belarus uh
from armenia
um and uh
and uh and tajikistan even and these are
these are all members of the csto
the reason seems to be uh that with
tokyo's justification at least let's say
is that he has identified these
protesters uh as armed groups as bandits
as terrorists and that would allow for
him to invoke the the csto article that
would enable him to bring in foreign
foreign troops but um are these really
uh foreign funded terrorists that he has
made out
or are they uh
are they democracy uh defenders are they
people who want to see reforms in this
country or are they
at least the armed ones remnants or
owing obedience to the former uh
president uh north of town nazarbayev
and his network and his people uh who
control uh still significant um parts of
the country or or who owe allegiance to
him and so mr tokai of president okayev
may not be giving away all uh the
information that he has uh and and is
casting this story in a particular light
in order uh to have brought in the csto
uh foreign peacekeeping force um there
is an awful lot of confusion at the
moment especially with the internet down
we will endeavor to to try to update our
viewers with information about what's
happening in kazakhstan as we can as
soon as we can get it
all right thanks so much robin foster
walker there